Tick Tock is full of beauty hacks so I  gathered some of the most hype texts to  test out for myself the first hack is  using a makeup sponge to stamp on a  super easy rainbow eyeshadow look even  though the eyeliner part was apparently  a little too advanced for me I think I  would definitely use a sponge to stamp  on eyeshadow again the next hack is  applying press-on nails with gel glue to  make them last longer so to start I'm  gonna apply a base gel to all my nails  and cure for 90 seconds going One Nail  at a time I'm gonna apply a thin layer  of gel glue on my actual nail and also  put some inside of the Press on I'm  applying the Press on with even  consistent pressure and Flash carrying  that for 15 seconds after applying each  nail I'm curing all of them for 90  seconds I'm gonna finish it off with a  thin layer of gel top coat and cure that  for 90 seconds I think the nails feel  really good